hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update now this isn't really gaming
news but the Star Wars Episode 7 cast
has just been announced and we really
had to share it with you this picture of
the cast was released and in it you can
spot the director of episode 7 JJ Abrams
right in the middle returning members of
the original cast include Harrison Ford
Carrie Fisher Mark Hamill Anthony
Daniels Peter Mayhew and Kenny Baker and
they'll be joined by some newcomers to
the Star Wars universe including John
boyega Daisy Ridley Adam driver Oscar
Isaac Andy Serkis Domhnall Gleeson and
Max von Sydow while EA has announced
before that they don't plan on making
games that mimic the movies that doesn't
mean we won't get some cameos or hear
these characters voices in some of the
upcoming games Abrams said about the
announcement quote we are so excited to
finally share the cast of Star Wars
Episode seven it's both thrilling and
surreal to watch the beloved original
cast and these brilliant new performers
come together to bring this world to
life once again we start shooting in a
couple weeks and everyone is doing their
best to make the fans proud for more
gaming news & star wars news because
Star Wars be sure to stay tuned to
gamespot com